WORLD."
IT IS JUST ABOUT HALF PAST 6:00
HERE IN ABU DHABI.
I'M BECKY ANDERSON FOR YOU.
THE WORLD NEEDS TO GROW UP AND
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THAT BLUNT MESSAGE FROM BRITISH
PRIME MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON AS
HE ADDRESSED THE U.N. GENERAL
ASSEMBLY ON WEDNESDAY.
HE URGED FELLOW LEADERS TO
LISTEN TO THE WARNINGS OF THE
SCIENTISTS, AND COMMIT TO MAJOR
CHANGES TO CURB GLOBAL WARMING.
HE ALSO TOUTED THE UPCOMING
CLIMATE SUMMIT SET TO TAKE PLACE
IN GLASGOW, THE UK, THIS
NOVEMBER, CALLING IT A TURNING
POINT FOR HUMANITY.
>> MY FRIENDS, THE ADOLESCENCE
OF HUMANITY IS COMING TO AN END.
AND MUST COME TO AN END.
WE ARE APPROACHING THAT CRITICAL
TURNING POINT, IN LESS THAN TWO
MONTHS, IN JUST OVER 40 DAYS,
WHEN WE MUST SHOW THAT WE ARE
CAPABLE OF LEARNING AND MATURING
AND FINALLY TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
DESTRUCTION WE ARE INFLICTING
NOT JUST UPON OUR PLANET, BUT
UPON OURSELVES.
IT IS TIME FOR HUMANITY TO GROW
UP.
>> NINO DOS SANTOS IS IN LONDON.
THE PRIME MINISTER COULD HAVE
FOCUSED ON A WIDE RANGE OF
ISSUES.
INSTEAD HE SPENT HIS ENTIRE
SPEECH TO WORLD LEADERS AND THE
WORLD WATCHING ON LOCKED IN ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
JUST EXPLAIN WHAT YOU BELIEVE IS
BEHIND THIS AGGRESSIVE APPROACH.
>> WELL, THE BACKDROP TO THIS IS
CLEARLY THE UPCOMING COP-26
CLIMATE CHANGE SUMMIT THAT IS
GOING TO BE HAPPENING ON HIS OWN
SHORES IN ABOUT SIX WEEKS' TIME
IN GLASGOW.
AND THE RUN-UP TO ALL OF THIS
HAS BEEN PLAGUED BY QUESTION
MARKS OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
DIPLOMATIC EFFORT TO TRY AND
CLENCH A DEAL ON CLIMATE CHANGE
HAS BEEN ENOUGH AND WILL SEE ANY
OF THE INITIATIVES RUBBER
STAMPED AT THE END.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IS A
PRIME MINISTER USING THIS SPEECH
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO KNOCK
HEADS TOGETHER WITH WORLD
LEADERS, TO TELL THEM HOW HE
THINKS THEY CAN COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND AMID VARIOUS REPORTS
THAT SHOW CONSISTENTLY U.N.
REPORTS BY THE WAY THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TARGETS THAT PEOPLE
ARE SIGNED ON TO IN 2015, THE
WORLD IS WOEFULLY BEHIND.
AND TYPICAL STYLE HE BORE REED
FROM THE GREEK POET SOPHACLEES
AND THE MUPPETS.
THIS IS HOW HE USED KERMIT THE
FROG TO SELL TO THE WORLD
LEADERS.
>> WHEN KERMIT THE FROG, KERMIT
THE FROG SANG, IT'S NOT EASY
BEING GREEN, YOU REMEMBER THAT
ONE, I WANT YOU TO KNOW HE WAS
WRONG.
HE WAS WRONG.
IT IS EASY.
IT IS NOT ONLY EASY.
IT IS LUCRATIVE AND RIGHT TO BE
GREEN.
HE WAS RATHER RUDE TO MISS
PIGGY, I THOUGHT.
>> AS YOU IMAGINE, THEY ARE A
TOUGH CROWD TO PLEASE WITH HIS
HUMORISTIC OVERTONES THERE.
BUT WHAT IS HE PRESCRIBING HERE
IS AN ALTERNATIVE.
HE SAYS IT COMES DOWN TO COAL,
CARS, CASH AND ALSO TREES.
SO WHAT HE WANTS TO DO IS
PROPOSE THAT ALL OF THE WORLD
COLLECTIVELY PLEDGES TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY, AND BIG
COUNTRIES TO PHASE OUT COAL AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE, IN PARTICULAR
PRAISING EFFORTS BY CHINA AT
THIS UNGA TO STOP BUILDING
COAL-POWERED PLANTS OUTSIDE
THEIR COUNTRY AND THE UNITED
STATES WITH THE RECENT DOUBLING
OF THE MONEY THEY PUT TOWARD T